heute will der bundestag das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz verabschieden und
dieses erhitzt bereits seit einigen
tagen vor allem die gemüter von
querdenkern und corona leugnern um die
sichere arbeit des bundestags zu sichern
wurden mittlerweile zwölf anträge für
versammlungen funktion erläutern und
gegendemonstranten rund um den bundestag
abgelehnt
trotzdem heißt das natürlich nicht dass
es nicht zu demonstrationen kommen kann
und deswegen wollen wir einmal genau
dorthin schauen vor dem reichstag steht
nun mein kollege hannes radigk und haben
es man sieht hinter dir sind schon
einige menschen
was genau ist da los was befürchtet oder
erwartet man heute genau seit den frühen
morgenstunden strömen also hier rund um
den reichstag auf die zufahrtstraßen
gegner der infektionsschutz gesetze ins
gegner aber auch recht teilweise auch
verschwörungstheoretiker die sich alle
zu einem bunten haufen zusammen finden
die auch die demonstrationsverbote eben
ignorieren und trotzdem sich hier
versammeln auf den zufahrtstraßen rund
um den deutschen bundestag
ihr erklärtes ziel ist eben die
abgeordneten daran zu hindern heute
morgen zu ihrem arbeitsplatz zu kommen
wo gegen 12 oder ab 12 die neue
verabschiedung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes stattfinden
soll
die polizei ist mit einem massiven
aufgebot hier vor ort wir haben
beobachtet dass die abgeordneten
trotzdem an die absperrungen
herankommen oder bundestags ausweise
zeigen und dann eben doch ins parlament
kommen können und heute ihre arbeit zu
machen
es ist ein bunter auch wissend wie
gesagt querdenker die eben die
demonstrationen auch angemeldet haben es
sind aber auch in sachsen das heute buß
und bettag
wir haben das in leipzig gesehen dass
fußball hooligan sich eben unter diese
demonstranten gegen diese
infektionsschutz gegner gemischt haben
dass es auch heute hier so ist in
teilweise auch aggressive menschen die
besoffen oder schon angetrunken sind die
ein wenig desolat und aggressiv würden
es sind aber auch ganz normale menschen
hier die sagen wir finden diese
maßnahmen übertrieben und wollen das
kundtun
es ist also eine einen nicht homogene
mischung von menschen pro wir glaube ich
auch differenzieren müssen was ihre
absichten tatsächlich sind faschisten
sind heute auf der straße sie sind gegen
das was heute im parlament beschlossen
werden soll
und das tun sie relativ lautstark und
ungefähr 50 prozent von ihnen tragen
masken 50 prozent nicht und was sie aber
alle gemeinsam nicht machen dass es
abstand halten und das wird sicherlich
heute auch eine rolle spielen ob die
polizei das dulden wird oder diese
aufzüge dann doch schlussendlich
versucht aufzulösen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren